[Music]  my best friend has been avoiding me ever  since I told him I hate his  ex-girlfriend I don't really I was just  trying to make him feel better after  their breakup is there a way to come  clean that's a tough one  [Music]  now I can't tell you the best piece of  advice but I can tell you the worst  piece of advice I feel like you already  messed up probably shouldn't have said  you hated ex-girlfriend when you didn't  you know what I mean you probably could  have just been like oh you're gonna be  so much happier like now we can go do  guys stuff again all that stuff um so I  don't really know how to I don't really  know how to help a liar yeah sure I mean  you could day to yourself  [Music]